where did you decide for example just to
take one example to this interesting
almost symbolic use you have of cool
colors and warm colors you know that
happened in Chronos that I was doing
Kronos with Guillermo Navarro and then
we did a short it's a low angle shot of
his Greece opening at the diary of the
alchemist and he had a warm light on the
left and and a very cool blue on the on
the right and I saw that contrast and I
can't explain it I just went this is so
beautiful I felt completely in love with
it and I've been then codifying color
ever since and and it came from it
actually was very clear and I was
already codifying for example red in in
in Kronos I didn't want red in anything
but things that meant life blood the
little granddaughter of this was Greece
and and everything was blue and
everything but it was very rudimentary
but it came from a quote that Fellini
did he said when one transitioned from
silent to sound one may the point of
working the sound as an expressive tool
as a narrative tool and he says and when
I went from black and white to color I
made a point to codify the caller as a
narrative tool and I thought that that
is true every single and if you watch
somebody that encompasses the entire
history onto modern cinema like Alfred
Hitchcock you see how he uses every
single tool that lands on his lap you
know the translucent ceiling under on
the lodger you can there's nothing on
film that in my opinion can be casual
the type of film I want to do I want to
codify everything again when I was a
little kid reading about schools of
painting medieval painters and the
symbolist both feel their paintings with
symbols and you you know when I when I
go with my kids to a museum of course
you can look at the picture and it's
powerful and it's beautiful but then I
tried to discuss it a little bit of
reference about who
why and for example you know and we see
a painting of Susan and the old and the
elderly or lead and the swan or
Polyphemus and Galatea
you know itself Allah know the myth if
you explain them that Polyphemus is a
jealous Sicilian Cyclops it explains a
lot of things on the painting and and I
think that there is in film I think that
we see film silent film evolve and you
see the tools being built and then you
see it reach an absolute apex you know
absolute perfection
von Stroheim screed Chaplin citylights
Keaton the general more now Dreier you
know they become true visual essays like
if you decompose vampyre thinking about
the idea of it being a memento mori you
can make sense of it but you're you
truly dealing with symbols and images
which are polyvalent and and very strong
and that discourse when sound came comes
in it really super imposes a structure
that existed from the early days that
came from theater which is dramaturgy
which is the script to plot the
characters and there is now a more
complete work and a more complete form
in many ways but the discourse often
just refers to that element and in many
ways we still this discuss films without
taking an account the melodic musical
rhythmic color when you discuss a
painting you discuss the strength of a
stroke is it a single stroke you know is
Picasso detailing the the body of the
ball in in a single stroke is that is
masterful is it a series of strokes is
it ponte ism you know there is a
plasticity to film that is a language in
itself and its best but i think should
be this caused in those terms so it's
it's it's it's a love of it that i think
changes after silent cinema but silent
cinema to me
I see greed and
is a perfectly amazing